they're discussing chris virtual
off-season programs where
like everyone else who's working at home
you're using teleconferencing software
facetime zoom
just good old-fashioned phone calls to
have the sessions that you otherwise
would have in your team facility the
thing i'm concerned about chris let's
start with that
how effective do you think it's going to
be what's is it a replacement to having
all the guys in a room
hearing from the coach seeing the
coach's demeanor body language getting
the messaging watching the film that way
how hard will it be to replicate that if
everyone is sitting at home looking into
their laptop yeah you're not going to be
able to replicate that you know just
being in a room with a coach who can
make eye contact with you make sure
you're paying attention you know you
know again you're going to be
more conversations in a meeting room to
where players are going to ask questions
hey what do i do when the defender does
this or what do i do when you know the
offense you know lines up in this
formation there's gonna be little
nuances lost here let alone not
necessarily concerned about the
classroom work but it's the the
walkthroughs and things like that the
little field work you can do where you
really make your best most headway in
the off season you know whether that's
throwing rats to the wide receivers or
having a walk through on hey we're gonna
try to implement this part of our
offense today let's go out on the field
and get a little jog and get a feel for
these new plays and new formations we
might install this year you know all of
that's going to be lost hey the virtual
reality stuff it'll help it's something
certainly but to say that it's uh the
same as a normal off-season routine no
way and then you know it's gonna be
frustrating there's
there's there is so many issues right
now with this whole thing and you know i
want to comment more about it but
but right now yes it's
not well what what
let's let's break it down from a
physical standpoint it's one thing to
sit there and learn at home and
participate in meetings where it's no
replacement for being in the room and
hearing from the coach directly but
staying in shape right under the
direction of who are you going to be out
there with your phone is that and how is
the strength coach
you're going to have to have
conversations with with 90 different
guys over the course of a day as they
get their workouts in i mean it just
seems like it's going to be very
difficult to pull it off to have a
workout routine for everyone to have
anything that would remotely simulate
practice and then what happens if
somebody gets injured where do you go
sure now i i think you're allowed to go
to the facility to get you know your
your attention and training and etc but
um
if you need surgery who's gonna who's
gonna perform surgery james andrews the
the noted orthopedic surgeon is not
doing tommy john's surgery indefinitely
because of the covet 19 pandemic if you
have some sort of an injury from the
offseason work at home that requires a a
surgical procedure do you have to wait
for three or four months so there's a
lot of issues that can arise number one
trying to keep guys in shape and what
happens if they overdo it and they end
up getting injured
right and how do you work out really i
mean who's gonna have access not
everybody's gonna have a weight room in
their house you know maybe the top two
three guys on the roster who are making
you know ten twelve million dollars a
year yeah maybe they have a workout room
in their house but the bottom roster
guys who are making hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year they're not
going to have so so how are you going to
orchestrate that you're going to tell
guys to go in the backyard and you're
just gonna have to make up like
grassroot type workouts push-ups sit-ups
sprints body squats i mean you know
that's where these weight coaches are
gonna have to be get really creative you
know and then also added in this fact
mike you know if i'm a quarterback and
i'm playing man i'm starting to stress
out this is the time of the year where
you start i'd like to start throwing
some footballs i'd like to start
throwing to some receivers a little bit
you know start getting going get my arm
in shape just work on some of the
mechanical issues that i might have as a
quarterback that would really start to
stress me out too so these are all
things that are really going to be tough
you know during the lockout year of 2011
guys could still get together and go
have a workout together and hey let's go
lift weights and then we'll go over to
the field and we'll throw balls and do a
workout on the field for an hour you
can't do any of that this year how are
you going to do that you're not going to
be able to organize a group of players
and go somewhere and
you know not be
yeah go ahead yeah what if they decide
they're going to do it anyway we've seen
video of the basketball courts in the
soccer fields what if tom brady decides
the hell with coronavirus i got a season
to get ready for mike evans chris godwin
oj howard cameron breit we're getting
together and we're going to work on our
playbook together and we're going to do
it away we're going to go to my ranch in
montana and no one's going to know
uh what's to stop guys from doing that
uh you're right mike i didn't and i'm
not gonna lie if i was one of the if i
was tom brady or one of those guys i'd
probably do it because i would be i'd
probably you know in my stubborn young
playing days i'd be hey you know i'm
young i'm healthy screw this
you know hey are you sick or you sick no
great let's go to my ranch somewhere or
let's go somewhere to where yeah we can
get together and throw balls and work
out a little bit i i selfishly yes would
have a hard time with that you know
these players especially the
quarterbacks are type a ocd
psycho personalities that you know it's
hard to feel
i i i wouldn't feel comfortable in life
if i went a week or two this part of the
year without starting to be able to
throw football so i would think that is
going to be something that a guy like
tom brady or drew brees start to kick
around in their head a little bit
so you know and let's play this out as
good corporate citizens does the nfl
tell the players they're not allowed to
do that and will there be discipline if
they do it i mean there's discipline if
anybody dares to speak out against the
plan to go forward with the draft that's
far less important from a public health
standpoint than
discipline being imposed on players who
defy orders to not congregate i mean
look there's a hell of a rabbit hole
that is shaping up here and it's all
unfolding in real time and and as you
know we're worried about more important
things in life you've got these other
things that are going to potentially
happen that we're really not maybe
paying attention to the stage is set
chris
for
uh one or two groups of teammates
beginning that process the next thing
you know word's going to get around and
more are going to do it it's going to be
a fascinating dynamic to watch over the
next couple of months because i'm with
you these guys are young they feel
invincible that they
probably already had it anyway i had a
cold a few weeks ago that probably was
corona i'm fine i gotta be ready for
football season i can't worry about
getting sick it's not gonna affect me
look i'm an adonis i'm not gonna get
sick you know that attitude that mindset
that permeates everything they do
this is something the nfl better be
ready for because if we start seeing you
know a drone that pops up over a
practice field somewhere and it's all
these recognizable names and faces down
below defying local orders to stay
indoors that's not a good look for
anybody
no it's not and i think you know to your
point mike i think that's the nfl
probably needs to send an email to all
players and reach out to make sure that
doesn't happen you know it is it is the
duty of an nfl player to show the
leadership for society a little bit that
way and this is the way of the world
right now and you know you listen to our
president listen to any of the experts
they want people away from each other
work in a shutdown that is that is the
way it's got to be if people got video
and saw tom brady and aaron rodgers out
working you know with other teammates on
a field you know it's going to just
embolden the other other stubborn dumb
young 22 year olds they go oh screw it
brady's out throwing with his receivers
you know i'm gonna go over to the field
and and play flag football with my
friends today because i'm bored or we're
gonna go play a pickup basketball game i
don't care i'm young and healthy so i do
think the nfl has a responsibility there
to show some leadership and get the word
out to their players to say hey let's
let's not do this right now that's not
the right time it's not a good look it's
not good for our league it's not good
for society
you know sometimes when you have an open
forum like this where we can kick around
these ideas and you don't have to worry
about a radio clock some good ideas
percolate not that this is a good idea
but we've tripped over something that i
think needs to be on people's radar
screens as april arrives and this is
normally the time that guys would start
getting together again you're going to
have teammates that want to get together
and it's going to happen and the nfl
needs to get out ahead of it and see
this attitude that is that is permeating
everything the nfl says and does right
now that it's business as usual but for
we're not going to open the facilities i
i think that i think that
the nfl's position may very well be we
can't control what these guys do on
their own we hope that everyone complies
with all local directives and state
directives and national directives but
we can't make them do it they're on
their own time and they're allowed to do
whatever they want it's going to be an
interesting issue for the nfl to deal
with something that i'm going to i'm
going to poke around a little bit yeah
see if the league has a position on this
because i i people need to be thinking
ahead of where we are right now and i
don't think there's enough of that going
on with the nfl i think there's so much
focus on the draft is coming the draft
is coming the draft is coming they're
not thinking about other issues that may
be popping up over the next few months
but mike i agreed i think that's what
bothers me more than anything you're
right it's fine to try you know just you
know
keep trudging ahead with draft and free
agency there's nothing that we need to
do there to congregate in large groups
to make that happen so you can do
business as usual but here here's
another question for you
the poor rookies when they get drafted
what the hell are they going to do you
know again yeah their coach will be able
to facetime them they'll be able to talk
but they're not going to be able to go
meet up with their new quarterback and
go work work that way again like we saw
you know with the collective bargaining
agreement you know no off season in
2011. so they're they're going to be
really behind the eight ball rookies
this year and i think the other thing
that bothers me mike is you know like
you said
it doesn't it just it feels like the nfl
right now is just going i think it's
going to be all okay by the time august
of september comes around what bothers
me is we don't hear any rumors or
anything like we do with the other
sports who are kicking around ideas to
how to make their season work right now
the nfl is just being the old stubborn
nfl and saying nope it'll all work out
we'll be in training camp and we're
going to play in front of 80 000 people
and the season will go on yeah i just
don't know about that right now and i
don't feel like we're hearing any
leadership of ideas or brainstorming
that way and i think that's a little
concerning to me as well and that's one
of the things we're trying to do with
this platform we're trying to identify
the issues in the hopes that people do
start thinking ahead of where we are
right now and i've yet to hear anything
like that i haven't gotten that phone
call hey you know we're just acting this
way uh we really do have it covered i've
i've all i've heard is that the people
are focused on the draft to draft the
draft and we'll worry about everything
else after that so that's all coaches
have heard too mike
that's
that's 22 fewer days to plan for what's
coming and for what may happen when july
august september roll around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports